[Musique]
J ne peux pas se permettre le sérieux Hemmingway
du cinéma l'homme est infesté de
disciples Je suis l'apôtre tout comme moi
et Dieu comment pourriez-vous nous différencier
[Musique]
ne parlez pas du film donc vous êtes tous
les gars essaient de comprendre, c'est que
ce dont parlent ces films, nous ne
savons pas vraiment ce que c'est, non James, il l'
invente au fur et à mesure,
il l'a fait avant les
films et le français, ce sont des mystères,
monsieur Hannaford, voudriez-vous s'il vous plaît aller
vers le bas
mais il crée que tu dois détruire c'est une
compulsion veux que je t'apporte un autre
endroit
quels que soient les fous de vrais fous
eh bien le voici si quelqu'un veut le voir
[Musique]
toi